all right I don't know if this how this
works but I'm Brooks this is Nick this
is Cornell and the show might not ever
make it onto YouTube
[Music]
I'm like genuinely excited to go camping
now like this is a delight yeah when you
when you first talked about this I
thought it was just a terrible idea and
I'm still on the fence about it a big
fan of performing at that comedy club
haha cafe that's where I did my first
set ever really yeah I would I did an
open mic and there was like probably 50
people there and that's Hugh he wrote 50
comics also and then this guy before me
came on stage with the actual dog pulled
a gun out held it to the dog's head
instead of you guys don't laugh at my
jokes I'm gonna kill this dog first of
all that's a lot of crazy things also
it's a national lampoon's magazine cup
yeah it's a cup that so he stole the
joke he ripped off and brought a gun and
made everybody upset and scared
everybody there was there is one of the
first like open mics I went to in
Chicago when I moved there the kid one
of the kids he had a paper bag on stage
and I didn't know I knew it was inside
of it and then after like a minute he
hope he took a big thing of mayonnaise
out and a spoon and then after each joke
you need a [ __ ] big scoop of
mayonnaise let it's pretty foggy and
damp cuz worried is gonna be nice
yeah exactly well I brought my swimsuit
I did - I did you even go swimming
just got here to the camp beautiful day
in Malibu like always perfect sunny day
clearly as you can see yes someone left
some trash yeah
disrespectful but we'll get to have
recycle and make sure it's taken care of
all right look we're gonna camp let's
figure it out we did wait till we got a
four beer per person buzz before setting
everything up this should be this should
go pretty smooth yeah call Cornell and I
have camped in a weird weekend we camped
all the way up to Seattle and back one
time yeah yeah and Nick and I have
camped in Alaska together before yeah
I've kept with you but not together
yeah and I've cared with you and you
okay with you and I can't with you Oh
Nick for his own tent because he does
I've can't with you in this tent and it
was too small for two people
yesterday I text her I go do I need to
bring a tent or anything like now we're
just cuddle up
[Music]
Hey look at that [ __ ] oh yeah we're
snuggling dude come on dude don't be
uptight I might need help yeah help him
he turned his back on us yeah but if you
don't help you don't get access to
Chateau Rutherford let's get a bailout a
second of [ __ ] gonna alright also say
no more tough life
it's barely
why didn't you inflate it in there
that's it see oh yeah this isn't too bad
this isn't that bad I mean like I
wouldn't have probably have a [ __ ]
freaked out but yeah I would have a
freaked out about any more space close
to my buds yeah I'm gonna get pretty
lonely now that I'm saying I use a nice
pillow when I can't only the best
it's just like when you can't be on
anything you don't look at it when
you're sleeping they set up good to go
in here oh I forgot headlamps I got one
you got one yeah turn on now just in
case oh [ __ ] it's cool man the moon will
really shine through this darkness
[ __ ] neck lamps man all right time to
do some coke and just really relax
I think it may be nice to get a quick
shot of the older couple who's camping
trip we just show these people who are
like oh no soup for lunch hot dogs right
yeah on the grill or do you want to mail
the fire if we're gonna cook anything
over a fire hot dogs are the way to go I
think let's build a fire
yeah
[Applause]
wait who grabbed crushed red pepper
personal pan pizza amount of crushed red
pepper I got back to season the
asparagus myth man alright tell ya man I
love it you're coming love it
great job recall that great job the auto
latrine yeah oh nice
so you pee and then I was done yeah it's
a laid out the sand this is linen wait
we gotta put them in smaller pieces well
here look we got this now we need we
need to that kindling and stuff I got
this knife I bought this night with Nick
in Alaska I got to go in saw knife
well is a cool knife little small it's
not gonna you're not gonna shatter wood
with them yeah yeah that's everything
Nick and I got our camping trip to
Alaska is a sip our Sarah Palin memorial
switchblade should have been VP it with
a rock also I wouldn't trust that Sarah
Palin knife at all alright yeah that's
what I was doing with the Smashing we
weren't here buzz right now we'd be
really frustrated the first rule of
camping is relax
off-camera I was smashing the wood with
the rock and this is what I was able to
come up with so little help whatsoever
so for this rate we should be should be
hotdogs time in two and a half hours so
I think we're looking pretty good
started around down here do dinner
around three tongs we have anything we
knew about this trip for well over a
month we all packed this morning they're
all late we were all late yeah last time
is girls use some hobo hook the humans
ribcage may be thrown in the ocean we'll
get some dolphins
I had dolphins laughs hot dog I have a
friend who claims that dolphins are
smarter than humans he means it for real
and that's why dolphins have computers
and societies the bird scan seals in the
flavor I had a pretty late we lost a
[ __ ] dog yeah get it out all either
all right hold on hey save the dog there
hosted by no untoasted I might just do
only ketchup and mustard no one perfect
dough might be in the ballpark Wagyu
beef
there's really not terrible holding
they're pretty good
and now kisses for everybody so lunch
[Music]
[Applause]
this might seem odd put the weight the
way to that really nice this the point
is through the scariest window I've ever
seen oh this is my element man what is
this turtle sewer where Master Splinter
taught everyone ninjitsu okay kind of
dope can we support captain here so
where are we going you go up here and
then we hike over to there
and you've done this before yeah well
what this bin oh hell yeah they got it
going on
solid frizz yeah hit me this is
Cornell's people Northern California
Southern California home of they can
smell each other we should get those
guys some food yeah you guys should try
smoking weed it'll mellow you out oh I
guess my ex-wife I mean [ __ ] hits the
fan and hungry we're out here with no
technology nothing
just us surviving surviving in the wilds
of the elements with no camera crew or
and sorry camera guy sorry I got his
foot they're just completely alone
if you pointed out our walk and you told
us we were gonna do that he'd be like I
never mind you know way too much for you
to walk all right pretty far and now I'm
convinced the earth is indeed flat
make sense to me yeah like you see any
curve now that's the end
wow you're right dude so we're right at
the end this is it the end of there okay
those guys up there
we need hike past somebody else make up
a story where you're in the middle of
that they just like catch a little bit
of like big so I bit him so the people
walking past you have like a story to go
home with like yeah and I said that's
not my diarrhea
so I know she was eight but I fought her
I'm not gonna lie I won by a lot my
grandma said yeah I pee blood it's not
that big of a deal
what kind of weird piss competition
where's your grandma dude [ __ ] Yeah
right though oh [ __ ] pretty sick that's
very cool
wait why are we going down there
Goodridge that's we're gonna hang out
for a minute all right well it smells
like weed up here right yeah then I'd be
coor now yeah I knew it was chill up
yeah dude check it out Oh [ __ ] right
right would you take a zipline into the
ocean right now yes yeah I'm here for
sure yeah you had to hold on to it you
weren't like hooked up to it
yeah yeah that's really cool I wanna be
in that little Glen there don't you
order punch dick it's just here's the
thing here's what I will say it is a
pleasure and it is an honor to be
camping and hiking in such a beautiful
place [ __ ] drink it
but this is what I'm talking about like
absolutely gorgeous like it's
breathtaking
in every way and it's our job to take
care of it as humans
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey-ya players known our hike success
I'm disgusted with the fact that we
thought that that might be fun
hey oh yeah that's pretty cool
I'm not a balanced person
so nice to see your friend get in touch
with nature man yeah it's uh nice yeah
he's really feeling it he's loving it
out here I can't wait to make some tacos
but yeah we need your help right now
give me a second you can get up you lay
there all day BAE I'm enjoying the time
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
and yeah tonight that's a sick game but
I'm throwing a game you only come up
with camping sabzi buzz that need yeah
it's so hard to be your friend so you
have these tortillas the first taco bar
taco
I taste a bunch of sand dinner success
let me pack it down a little
[Laughter]
you got it they're gonna hang out in
there guys
Oh what anyone in art Anjali you want to
attend yeah thank you they were strong
joins I've ever seen you [ __ ] my buddy
right
I can't pass to her you think you're
better than us huh dude don't you owe
the drug smoking weed six
so that was it for camping for the day
we drank drank some bits I had some had
some treats we're gonna go to bed now
we're to wake up with the Sun I know
like five or six hours or maybe seven or
eight who knows then maybe another ten
anyway you know bed we're gonna make
some breakfast in the morning like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
so last night happened Cornell and I I
think hit a low point with knife catch
an important part about camping it's
friendship nick is still asleep we're
gonna wake him up with bacon and coffee
because that's what friends do yeah it
turns out this games much more dangerous
than knife toss for the old hands there
we go yeah I hope I don't spill this on
his face got some nice bacon perfectly
crisp
he's what if he was dead oh this is
close this hey man we got you some bacon
and coffee
you remember knife toss I wish we got to
stay out here camping cuz back in the
city is where everyone who's mad at me
lives so I'm not excited to go back
there yeah well people are mad at you
here to Brooks that's true but less mad
yeah nobody wants to have a talk
no god no yeah no down is this a worst
coffee you've ever had Nick nice an
alert ready to take on the day it's
really bad huh breakfast
yes all right now the first part of
camping pack in two minutes throw it all
in there we gotta go
[Music]
so over I would say is a big success to
trip yeah 100 moped I've got here we
made delicious hot dogs showed you guys
how to cook yeah Google search hot dog
and that's exactly what you'll find
something looks exactly exactly crispy
outside I'm cooked in the middle
perfect we went on a nice hike we're the
Foot Clan trains go to the Ninja Turtles
movie and would have a nice beautiful
hike to whine hike that me picked up a
bug picked up a bug that was exciting
yeah got back here that's when things
get a little hazy taco dinner was really
good delicious that was actually
probably the best thing we did yeah
classic camping we drank a little bit
more after the tacos and then we had a
just deep intellectual conversation and
would write read and look I read two
books after the cameras went off yeah I
got one and a half done it was kind of
like turned from a hangout and just like
a thing yeah a lot of ideas were written
down last night but definitely didn't
throw knives at each other so overall I
would say a camping trip success
find actually as those foot I had a
great time okay yeah no I had it success
[Music]
you